[Music]
on this Tuesday night please to further
extend the Gaza pause as more hostages
are released by their Hamas
captors how one 12-year-old says he and
other children were treated and more
Canadians finally returned from Gaza was
very scared mission accomplished success
everything was successful how 41 workers
were finally rescued from that collapsed
tunnel in India how to protect protect
kids from online Predators for us there
was no red flaves at all the advice for
parents and flying on waste cooking oil
and animal fat is this transatlantic
first a path to sustainable aviation
fuel global national with Donna freezen
good evening and thanks for joining us
after 53 days in captivity 12 more
hostages Are Back In the Arms of their
families tonight the pause in fighting
and in Gaza has held for a fifth day
they were handed over by Hamas to the
Red Cross two Thai citizens and 10
Israelis among them nine women and one
girl the oldest 84-year-old ditsa Hyman
a retired social worker the youngest
17-year-old Mia Linberg who was
kidnapped with her beloved dog Bella and
her mother all are safe in Israel now in
exchange another 30 Palestinian
civilians detained in Israeli prisons
were released more war aid has made it
into Gaza and for now Israel's
bombardment has been replaced with
relief what started as a 4-day pause has
been extended to 6 days and there are
negotiations underway to extend it even
further though Israel is not backing
away from its vow to destroy Hamas
Danielle Hamin begins our coverage from
Jerusalem
tonight 10 more Israeli citizens and two
Tha Nationals are now back in Israeli
territory Tuesday night but there were
no noticeably absent hostages in the
latest Handover no young children and no
sign of the youngest of them all he's
not a soldier he's not a grownup person
that could have done anything toward him
when they invaded Israel
so I I have no reason why they did what
they
did baby cfir now 10 months old is no
Soldier but like every other hostage
including his brother and parents he is
a bargaining chip according to Israel
he's no longer with Hamas but with
another militant group possibly
complicating efforts to free
him those who have made it out have
appeared in stable physical condition
food when made available consisted of
mostly rice and bread access to toilets
could take hours some were kept in
groups with other
hostages 12-year-old etan halomi seen
here reuniting with his mother after 52
days in captivity spent his first 16
days alone in a closed room he told his
family he was forced to watch videos of
the October 7th attacks
Shak and that whenever a child in
captivity cried they threatened them
with a weapon so they'd shut up says his
aunt under the terms of the temporary
ceasefire agreement 108 0 Palestinian
women and teenagers have now been
released from Israeli
prison most were being held indefinitely
without being charged or tried according
to Amnesty International some of the
detainees have also been subjected to
torture at the hands of Israeli
authorities neus hammad was 14 when she
was arrested accused of involvement in
the attempted murder of an Israeli
settler
at 16 she was one of the youngest female
prisoners in Israeli
prison I'm very hopeful that the prisons
will be emptied God willing she says
with fewer Israeli women and children
held hostage in Gaza the negotiations
will soon center around Israeli men and
soldiers which will likely change the
terms of any temporary ceasefire in 2011
when Hamas handed over Israeli soldier
gilad Shalit after 5 years in cap ity
Israel had to agree to release a
thousand Palestinian prisoners in return
Donna Daniel Hamin in Jerusalem tonight
thanks roughly 270 Canadians and others
with ties to this country are still
stuck in Gaza some of those who got out
have made it home now and are talking
about what they endured during more than
a month of Israeli bombardment Hadi
petruk met one couple who landed in
Halifax late last night and a warning
some of the details in her story our
graphic it was a joyous welcome chance
at the airport giving way to
emotion 72-year-old khil mana and his
wife 68-year-old nabila ner traveled to
Gaza to visit her elderly mother in
mid-september they intended to stay 20
days the brutal conflict between Israel
and Hamas trapped them in Gaza for more
than twice as long without their
medications scrounging for food and
water water Devastation all around them
moving three times after each home they
stayed in was bombed one time I sat in
in the
bed and then my wife she tell me and
come to take a lunch and I go to take a
lunch 2 minutes swear to God and after
the buming and the bed where is I sit
complete the wall destroy destroyed
difficult memories they can't leave
behind now of an entire family of
neighbors killed and survivors awaiting
rescue I see the cut people this cut
under the ground pieces leg head and
bleed in and nobody help because doesn't
have machine to take them out they still
some people life now and nobody can take
take them out this return didn't come
easily the family frustrated by what
they say was a lack of information about
Khalil and nabila's status on the list
of Canadians approved to leave through
the Rafa Border Crossing into Egypt a
say they feel took too long especially
where I was getting calls from my
parents like pleading for help and
asking us to get them out what they have
seen I know it's not something that
they're going to recover very quick and
I hope to back the Beast again in in
Gaza he and his wife among the 450
Canadians who've crossed into Egypt
through the Rafa border so far Heidi pic
Global News Halifax Danfield
International
Airport after 17 days trapped in a
collapsed tunnel in India 41 workers are
finally
free this is the moment the first worker
surface pulled through a steel pipe
barely a meter wide government officials
were there to welcome them hours after
drilling through debris of Rock concrete
and Earth to reach them Crystal ganing
on the rescue and the
relief the rescue of 41 men ultimately
came down to a large banned method
called rat mining workers used handheld
machines and physically cleared away
Rubble tunneling deep into the mountain
side in Northern India like a rat would
burrow into the
ground you can see the result of our
efforts says Nasser one of the so-called
rat
miners displays of gratitude from The
Young construction workers as government
officials celebrated their safe return
return to the surface following the
collapse on November 12th a small access
route was dug horizontally to get oxygen
and food to the men getting them out
that way wasn't going to work big
equipment ran into snags and the rat
miners were called in they managed to
dig through and eventually insert a
smaller Escape tube less than 1 M wide
the workers lying on a wheeled stretcher
were pulled out by hand
they were building a tunnel to connect
popular cultural sites in the Himalayas
but the location is fragile and there
was a landslide before the tunnel
collapsed the men survived 400 hours
below the Earth's surface those at the
site celebrated word of their
rescue the state's chief minister is
following doctor's advice and says the
men will be sent home after they've been
medically cleared the rescued
construction workers are said to be from
some of India's poorest states questions
are being raised about the safety of
their work and why there wasn't an
Escape Route for the men Crystal ganing
Global News
London the parents of a 12-year-old BC
boy who died by Suicide are raising the
alarm about online Predators police have
linked his death in October to online
sexual extortion a crime that's on the
rise according to cyber
tip.com on Instagram or SnapChat it says
91% of victims are boys Angela Jung
helps explain what parents need to
know dangerous predators behind screens
can reach Young young victims easier
than ever before the online World though
it's an alternate reality it is still
reality and it can have real world
consequences RCMP and Prince George BC
shared 12-year-old Carson Cleveland took
his own life after being sextorted we've
talked to him about it
before but you never expect it to
come Alexandra Ford is a trafficking
Survivor she's using her trauma to
empower others to talk about Online
safety and consent we kind of wait until
our kids are a little bit older when
they're first navigating Intimate
Relationships but the reality is we can
start talking about consent with our
kids at 18 months old at 2 years old
latest numbers from Canada's national
tip line for reporting sexual crimes
show boys are predominantly being
targeted by Sexual extorter Boys
generally not being okay with sharing
feeling sharing vulnerability maybe
turning to um you know online support or
places or just self-medicating with um
social media and video game which I see
all the time following Carson's death
the federal government says it's an
example of how online threats can create
real world harm Canada's Public Safety
Minister says their long-promised online
harm reduction legislation will be
introduced soon it's a complicated space
to legislate in and on um but the urg of
moving I think is real these Predators
on the other side they know what they're
doing and it's criminal before this
becomes Long Ford says parents need to
gradually train their kids to use
gadgets when you're crossing the road
first your kids are in your arms right
like you have full control over
everything same with when they're first
using any sort of online application to
give tools to youth to handle life
online Angela Jung Global News burn
BBC if you or a young person in your
life need someone to talk to the kids
help phone number
is800 668
6868 it is confidential it's available
24 hours a day kids help phone also
provides resources for parents an
Ontario man who pleaded guilty to the
murder of a massage parlor employee has
been sentenced to life in prison with no
chance of parole for 10 years he was 17
at the time of the attack in 2020 24
yold Ashley arzaga was stabbed with a
sword another sex worker was injured
last year the man pleaded guilty in what
the judge found was an act of terrorism
motivated by so-called incel ideology
incel is short for involuntary celibates
it's a misogynistic movement that
promotes violence against women largely
through online chat rooms beyond Canada
I think it's it's a it's a it's a case
that the world is going to have um an an
interest in because it taking terrorism
to um to to chat room participation
leading to the commission of crime this
is believed to be the first time in
Canada a court has made a finding of
incel motivated terrorist activity
damning leak documents coming up what
the host of the latest climate Summit in
Dubai was planning to do that flies in
the face of the climate
talks representatives of 198 countries
along with climate scientists and
environmentalists are gathering in Dubai
this week it's cop 28 the latest United
Nations climate change conference it's
meant to be a pivotal moment to
accelerate action on reducing carbon
emissions though as Eric Sorenson
reports leaked documents suggests the
United Arab Emirates plan to use its
role as host to promote deals for its
National oil and gas
companies 2023 Is On Target to be the
hottest year on record climate
catastrophes are only increasing in in
number and intensity Canada saw the
worst Wildfire season ever 14 million
hectares burned and yet expectations for
serious climate action in Dubai are
under a cloud just two days before this
year's cop 28 Summit begins can the
world cut emissions in half as head of
this year's climate talks the CEO of the
United Arab Emirates National Oil
Company Sultan Al jabber has tried to
reassure participants he's serious about
climate change I uh want everyone to
know that we have the full political
will to support a successful uh cop 28
skepticism among climate Advocates has
turned to Serious mistrust after leaked
documents suggested the UAE is using the
Gathering to promote oil and gas deals
around the world it is completely
inappropriate for countries to use their
presidency roles to be pushing private
deals and it is egregious when the deals
that they're pushing are for fossil fuel
expansion projects the documents
obtained by the center for climate
reporting include talking points on oil
and gas development for 15 countries
Canada was not one of them meantime a
new UN report this month found major
producers are on course to increase oil
and gas production through 2030 and that
does include Canada governments can't
keep pledging to cut emissions under the
Paris agreement and then greenlighting
huge fossil fuel projects companies are
operating in Canada are producing more
oil and gas even though all of the
world's climate scientists have said
that is um incompatible with avoiding
irreversible climate catastrophe still
cop 28 will be deemed a success by many
if there is an agreement by the nearly
200 countries to phase out fossil fuels
now I close the vote this week the
European Parliament called for such a
deal in Dubai I will Advocate tirelessly
uh for a global phase out of unabated
fossil fuels but the first task facing
the UAE this week may be to dispel
doubts that the hosts of the climate
Summit have a hidden oil agenda Eric
senson Global News
Toronto Panama's Supreme Court has
declared unconstitutional a Canadian
mining company's contract to operate a
copper mine west of Panama's Capital the
decision was celebrated by demonstrators
outside the courthouse there have been
weeks of protests over the Panamanian
government decision to Grant a 20-year
extension of Mining rights to the local
subsidiary of canada-based first Quantum
minerals critics argued the contract
would damage a forested coastal area and
threaten Water
Supplies age-old spat ahead why Greece
and the UK are fighting over the
Parthenon sculptures
[Music]
again in the US MERS paid their respects
at a private memorial service for former
first lady Rosalyn Carter she died on
November 19th at the age of 96 past
American presidents and first ladies
were among those in attendance including
roslin's husband former President Jimmy
Carter who is 99 and emerged from
hospice care to be there they were
married for 77 years the funeral for
rosn Carter will take place
tomorrow Charlie Munger the longtime
Vice chairman and second in command to
Warren Buffett at Berkshire half away
has died the 99-year-old passed away in
California Buffett says Burkshire
Hathaway would not be where it is
without Monger inspiration wisdom and
participation a longtime dispute between
Greece and the UK over the Parthenon
sculptures has reignited they are
ancient Greek Treasures taken from the
Parthenon in Athens and brought to the
UK by British Diplomat Lord Elgen in the
early 19th century the Greek Prime
Minister on a visit to London said he
wants them returned if I told you that
you would cut the monaa in half and you
would have half of it at the Lou and
half of it at the British museum do you
think your viewers would appreciate the
the beauty of the painting after that
British prime minister Rishi sunak
canell a meeting with his Greek
counterpart Sak's office says both sides
had agreed not to publicly discuss the
marbles and relitigate what it calls
long settled matters the marbles have
been in the British museum since 1832
the UK maintains they were acquired
legally Greece has long campaigned for
their return to
Athens what's the best route to Greener
Aviation next what critics are saying
about sustainable
[Music]
fuel there he is right there oh my God
oh my goodness Lord there he is they got
him eyewitnesses captured the moment
ground workers at New Orleans Louis
Armstrong Airport detained a 38-year-old
passenger heat opened the emergency exit
and climbed onto the wing of a plane
while it was preparing to take off
though the plane hadn't started moving
yet that quick exit created some concern
on board but no one was heard
authorities say the man appeared to be
in the midst of a mental health
emergency a Boeing Dreamliner made
history today it became the first
passenger plane to make a transatlantic
flight powered entirely by sustainable
fuel the aviation industry is hailing it
as a groundbreaking milestone in its
quest to reduce fossil fuel emissions
many aren't convinced though and believe
this light was more for show than
anything of substance Redmond Shannon
explains test flight vs100 cleared for
takeoff from London Heath thr a Boeing
Dreamliner crossing the Atlantic Ocean
without a single drop of fossil fuel
Virgin Atlantic's dreamer in Chief Keen
to stress the sense of History nobody
thought it was going to be possible ever
for uh Lon haul Airlines to be able to
fly on sustainable aviation fuel and
today we hope to hope to prove the
Skeptics wrong sustainable aviation fuel
or saf is fuel made from crops waste
products or cooking oil currently saf
accounts for one tenth of 1% of aviation
fuel globally and is usually blended
with kosene to Power Jets saf emits the
same amount of carbon but the plants
used to make it absorb carbon as they
grow factoring in the carbon footprint
of production net emissions are reduced
by up to 80% it's going to take a while
before we can get enough fuel where
where every everybody's going to be able
to fly but you've got to start somewhere
by one estimate if only crops were used
to Power air travel in 2050 then an area
the size of India would be needed to
grow them we shouldn't see this little
marker of of progress or kind of an
experimental flight is a sign that we
could all now fly and and not worry
about our emissions the emissions are
still there and really need attention
unlike many other sectors Aviation
emissions are still Rising air travel is
forecast to surpass pre-pandemic levels
next year to break 2019s alltime record
electric aircraft are in development too
but are a long way off for l ha hold
flights ultimately lifting a 100 tons
off the ground requires tons of energy
for now at least flying less is the only
way to significantly reduce emissions
when you fly Redmond Shannon Global News
London and that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm Donna freezen tonight's
your Canada is New Westminster BC we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at global.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow by
[Music]
bye